all right we are in the Trump era of
hatred mail a quick reminder of what
hatred mail is because it's God's divine
plan that every child be born but an act
of patriotic duty to snuff that bastard
may be sets a foot near your stuff
Patriot Man written by Patriots who hate
David Pakman because America because
freedom yes here is an analysis from a
hatred about libel lawsuits and so on
and so forth let's take a listen
are you for real David Pakman you can't
even see how ridicule you are your show
should be closed down you [ __ ] and I
hope shrimp Jews with libel suits
how much is Soros paying you to be his
[ __ ] you despicable this is
unbelievable
IND of as to you homo go and grab some
[ __ ] I love how usually these hatred
males will include your why oh you are
when it should be you apostrophe re this
is different this may be the first time
where we've seen you apostrophe re when
it should be Y oh you are actually I was
actually going to make that exact same
point so now I have to make another one
which is the last sentence there if you
actually are gay why would you want to
go out and sexually assault women as our
president it doesn't really make any
sense no right no you wouldn't do that
it because you're not attracted to women
right okay funny how the free speech
always above all else crowd has no
problem with Trump wanting to sue media
outlets he doesn't like remember you can
turn hatred mail into something positive
with the coupon code hey tree at forty
will give you a huge discount off of
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership